[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you said about being wary of what you
say
or how you say it
apologies
we have an apology from mark brown and
any others
right
somebody move
somebody move that apology be accepted
please
so you know
can you hear me
all right yes mr chairperson uh we've
got
councillor nikki moved and councillor
wendy seconded
all right
all in favor
yes okay
thank
you obviously we can't have a public
forum
conflicts of interest
no conflicts of interest
item poor's current register of interest
any comments on that
confirmation of military jack um when
councillor wendy had a question on the
register
i'm sorry we
must say
counselor john mute
unmuted i'm unmuted um i have uh i'm not
a partner of the oxford plate anymore
what's the garden plate
okay
okay
confirmation of minutes of the offspring
oh community board second of february
2022
somebody know that they're a true record
please
i'm missing anybody who breathe it made
in their hand
thomas is
moving
and nikki is sickening
all right
against
carrie thank you
uh mata's rising
this is a lot more difficult than an
in-person meeting as we all know
right no matters
right
um oh it says i'm still muted is that
right no
you're right oh oh good um
thomas just um a question please about
the um
e charger
installation in pearson park
um
so it's two car parks but one is just to
be used
for everybody someone else on a sunday
is that correct
am i reading that correctly
my my understanding is that there are
three car parks to be available
two
already there for the
oh it does say three parts yes for salt
and the third one is for the fast
rapid charger
right thank you thank you
yes julie
just give shirley a second chilly on
mute
we can't hear you shirley i'm you
shady unfortunately is having problems
with the computer she's trying her best
could she put her question in chat
perhaps if she's not getting any joy
julie
there's a
screen down there says chat do you want
to type in your question
she said it's fine we can continue mr
chairperson
okay
right gonna
put your hand up
no
yes sarah
i'm not sure if this is where um i would
bring this up but i just had a
concern about um the current ground
water levels around the district at the
moment and
clearly the water tables are very high
um
is there any work being
done or can we find out if there's any
potential work being done and with ecan
about what the potential
um of flooding and stuff is going to be
over the winter time due to
how we're going to be stepping into
winter with an already high water table
i will follow that up mr chip you can
cool and just one other was um could we
also please um
be kept up to date on the um on the
timeline of progression for the new uh
oaxaca subdivision proposal that's being
put to the um
put in for the development and just so
that we're aware of when things
are going to be
read and go to the next steps
and sort of what's happening along the
way
yes mr chairperson and through you it's
my understanding that the board will be
kept updated with that whole process
so do we know where it is right now is
it literally just a piece an application
sitting on a desk or is it
i'm sure tracy will be able to tell
hi yes um no it's more than sitting on a
desk so it's going through all the
preliminary work with the
applicant and planning and
all the
teams involved in that so there's an
initial assessment process that gets
undertaken and that informs a report
that goes to council in terms of how the
options around how to treat the plan
change so
um the length of time of that really
depends on how fast they get information
to us so it's still in that very very
initial step um and i think like i'm
happy to circulate and the link to the
good planning website which sets out
really nicely all the steps that the
plan change follows and then we can
certainly keep you updated with where
that goes to but i'll send through that
link but yep absolutely aware that um
you would like to and should be kept
updated we were at in terms of that
process so yep
i can assure you that there will be a
very large number of people opposed to
it
right moving on to
dignitas presentations we haven't gotten
i was just wondering if we could have an
update on the um
two resource consents we discussed the
last meeting the the church in
horrorville and the
landfill proposed by oxford it might be
more appropriate to discuss them in the
workshop afterwards but
i did actually i sent an email out
following our last meeting to the uh on
board to update you so there hasn't been
any change since that update but i i
will certainly let you know if anything
does change
thank you tracy
right um
when do we run affect kristen
um can we do it now mr chairperson under
deputation
trust you're in charge
oh thank you very much um
so thank you for
allowing me to come along and
provide some information to the board
for those of you who don't know me my
name's chris brown i'm the manager of
community and recreation
for waimakariri district council i know
most of the the board members here i've
had interactions with them uh in the
past
and also hello to
all of the other listeners that are out
there who may be interested in some of
the information
that i've got for you so
i'll provide a bit of information around
the stockpile of dirt which is at
mandeville at the moment
and then i'll um i'll be happy to take
some questions from members of the board
um so on the 20th of january we received
information
um that there was some soil and that had
been dumped on north air road
and
we went and quickly had a look at it and
then
um decided that it would be prudent for
us to
put a fence around it and some shade
cloth on
that fence due to the fact that we
weren't able to determine exactly what
was in the soil and that from a visual
inspection on site
it looked as though
there was
more than just soil there
we could see plastic and other things
which are in it as well
um following um putting the fence around
the outside of it we contacted tonkin
and taylor
who are
[Music]
experts in contamination testing
they went and undertook a an assessment
of the
site
the process that they went through was
to take 10 soil samples and four samples
of
material that they could actually
take out
they
the samples came back with the tin soil
samples
not having
any asbestos in them but two of the
solid samples that they took out
were containing
um
asbestos material
the asbestos material that they found
i'll read a little bit from the tonkin
and taylor
report tnt collected 10 soil samples
from across the surface of the stock
bonds of metabolic analysis for asbestos
and soils heavy metals
and hydrocarbons
to provide an initial indication of
potential soil contamination fragments
of flat cement sheet and curved cement
bound fibrous material suspected to be
acm were observed on the surface of the
stockpiles four samples were suspected
um and uh submitted for liberty analysis
and two of those four samples came back
with uh asbestos inside them
um
so
on sorry i'm flicking between between a
number of screens here so um
so
when we found out that information we
contacted the mental sports club to
start conversations with them around
how we would go about
ensuring that it was safe
the contamination expert tonkin and
taylor
in the assessment provided some
recommendations around what we should do
to
ensure that public safety
was looked after and that was our main
focus so the recommendations the report
identified that offense needed to be put
around it
and um we'd already done that we took a
worst-case scenario at the um start and
had already put that fence was shake off
it also suggested that um while not
necessary we could look at putting a
polymer layer on the outside of it um to
contain it absolutely um so we have gone
and done that as well and you'll see a
green substance which is on the outside
but it's basically a glue and just make
sure that everything
stays there
the important thing to note in those
samples that were taken um is that there
were no no asbestos found within the tin
soil samples um and the asbestos which
was found was um contained within the
um
in the bound substance and that means
that there's very little risk of
airborne asbestos
from the from the surface of that and
obviously now we've put that polymer
layer on
that
risk is basically removed
we
we're confident that public safety is
looked after in terms of the material
staying there um where it is in the
state with those um actions that we've
taken our next steps are to start to
work with mandeville sports club on
ann tonkin and taylor on what we can
actually do to get rid of the soil we
don't want it on site we want it removed
but we have to
there's a consenting process to go
through and there's also a contamination
disposal management plan that we
actually need to create as well so that
will involve tonkin and taylor doing
further testing over and above the 14
samples that they've done at the moment
to determine the extinct right
throughout the stockpile which is
approximately 2 000 square meters
they'll come up with that disposable
disposal management plan um and then
we'll review that um and and we can talk
to the community more around what that
actually entails and what steps will be
taken through that process to make sure
that the community um are both informed
and kept safe as well
um so that's that's an overview um i'm
happy to to take any questions um
from any of the
board members
thomas i can see with you i can see your
hand up thomas yeah okay i'll kick it
off um
i've got a few questions but i'll start
off with this uh why did it take over a
month to let the board know that this
was going on um i had phone calls the
week before well we were notified on the
friday was friday last week but i had
phone calls earlier in the week saying
have you seen the the dirt that's been
dumped at mandeville sports club and i i
thought i
had we cruised around i couldn't find it
and i thought nothing else of it so um
it's it's yeah it's very disappointing
it's taking them over a month for this
information to get to us is there any
reason why that was
yeah so there's a couple of reasons um
the first reason is we found out on the
20th
but as of the 20th um we didn't actually
know whether there was anything of any
concern within uh the stockpile itself
we got the contamination report back on
the 11th
um and then once we received that we had
to have a conversation with uh
mandeville sports club uh the remember
the site is leased by the mandeville
sports club um the council wasn't aware
that the soil was
going to be placed there in the first
instance so we had to have a
conversation with the mandeville sports
club about what actions they were taking
and
whether whether that involved their
insurance company or whether that
involved
any any legal
action that they might take so we had to
give them the opportunity
to have a discussion with them before we
went out to the community board and the
councillors and the rest of the
community so
once we were in a position to be able to
do that we let the community board
knowing the councillors know
i believe it was 45 minutes to an hour
before we actually put the press release
out to the wider community to let them
know as well
so we had to go through um those things
before we were before we were in a
position um to be able to let other
people know um
we would have liked to have done it
earlier at the earliest possible point
but we didn't want to
let people know before we had the
contamination results and also we didn't
want to jeopardize any um
future
actions which mandeville all the council
might
might want to go down so those are those
are the reasons
just it makes it very difficult when i'm
working and i
get calls from people saying have you
seen what's on the council's facebook
page
um and not even having a chance to have
read the email which was exactly the
same as the press release that was sent
out um and having people ring up and
asking if i know about it and then
saying well it happened a month ago
surely the community board was made
aware of it before this
and
me having to say basically i know as
much as
less than you do because i haven't even
seen it on facebook so
um it puts us it will put me in a very
difficult position but yeah that sort of
makes people question the value of the
community board when we
yeah aren't even given a heads up really
so so look in response to that uh we we
didn't want to let the community board
know and then wait to let the community
know and the community had already
obviously seen the dirt and they were
waiting for information to come out
from the council when we're in a
position to be able to release that
information
we gave it to the community board
and then gave it to the community with
only a small gap in the middle the last
thing we wanted to do is give it to the
community board and then wait a couple
of days for them to digest it before
going to the community
we didn't see the value
in doing that and wanted it to get to
the wider community as soon as possible
once we were able to do that so
in different circumstances we would
absolutely want to let the community
board know um sooner
so that um they had time to digest it
and and and uh see questions from the
community and work with the community as
well it just wasn't possible in this
instance i'm sorry
okay so secondly does the council have
any idea of
why this was done there and who it was
done by and what avenues are there for
the council to
sort of seek reimbursement for the costs
of removing this stuff because it's
going to be very expensive
uh yeah so some some good questions
there um we do know why the soil was
placed on site you'll be aware that the
mandeville sports club's been working
towards the completion of their concept
plan for about
eight years now and part of that is the
development of a walking and cycling
track around the outside of mandeville
domain a lot of that's already created
but probably about
four five six years ago um i'm sorry if
i'm wrong on those dates but um the
trees at the northia
road were removed and that created some
really uneven ground in between the
trees where the stumps are and so the
idea was to
get the soil and place that um in the
middle so that they could level that out
and actually create that cycle and
walking track so the intentions were
very good for a mandible sports club and
wanting to get that soil and
look where it comes from um uh at the
moment um that's that's not um something
which we've been focused on we've been
focusing primarily on ensuring that um
the public um safety um is looked after
um so that's been our main concern in
terms of putting that polymer on and
putting the fence and the shade cloth
around it
what avenues are being looked at
i can assure you that there are revenues
that are being looked at by mandeville
sports club at the moment
i would i won't go into the details of
what they are but i can say that they
are investigating um
what possibilities they have
and
what avenues they can take to look to
have it removed and then look at the
financial
financials around that as well you're
right um that that there will be a cost
involved in moving it and we don't know
what that is um we still have to
undertake the um management disposal
management plan
okay and lastly um i'm assuming it's
like an acrylic like type polymer that's
been sprayed on it to steal it how is
there a plan for maintaining that going
forward because it won't last forever it
must only last for like a month to two
months maximum i would have thought so
is there a plan to
to keep that monitored and up-to-date
and and
out of curiosity has he can be notified
yeah environment can be aware and uh yes
we will be the ones who will be making
sure um with the help of well tonkin and
taylor are going to be on the
consultants they're the experts in this
field and we'll be relying on them to
tell us um
how the poly malaya is performing and of
course that'll depend on weather and
rain and various things like that um but
i do believe it lasts for quite a lot
longer than a month um and um we'll just
rely on them to to let us know as
they're monitoring that as to whether or
not we just need to apply some more
thank you
right
right
ray you've got a question
you can hear me
yes i can you right yep yep chris
i walk over in that area um several
times a week with my dogs and my family
have seen it there i attended a mandible
sports club meeting of delegates um it
was after this date of the 25th of
january no mention of it was made at
that particular time and i'm mad as hell
um i'm not going to worry i'm not going
to be concerned because it'll take 40
years and i certainly won't be around in
40 years but my younger family certainly
will be
um
why was the mandible sports club who
knew it was being tested why didn't they
put signs up sooner and let the general
public know
why um is it that
i belong to the mandeville bowling club
they still haven't heard about this
asbestos
what type of asbestos is it
um how long has it been there
and um i'm sure if this was in the
middle of rangiora it'd be gone by now
so why are we waiting
uh so uh thank you for your questions
ray i think you've got about six
questions in there so
um uh i'll i'll start but when i stop um
please continue to ask those other
questions because i might have forgotten
so
so um
i believe you are saying you attended a
meeting on the 25th with the mandeville
sports club but there was no mention of
of it at the time
um what i can tell you is that when we
found out on the
20th
we uh didn't know that there was a
special asbestos in it at the time and
neither did the mandeville sports club
they didn't find out until the 11th 11th
once the preliminary contamination
assessment had been done
um as to whether there was any
contamination in the soil at all
in the meantime we made sure that we put
a fence up and put the shade cloth up
i'm taking the worst case scenario um so
from the 24th i believe it was we were
able between the 20th and 24th we
arranged for a fencing contractor which
are hard to get at the moment
to get there and actually put up that
fence and put up that shade cloth and
then we received the information on the
11th of january so when you were at that
meeting um the mental thought scope
wouldn't have been able to
actually tell you whether there was any
asbestos because they didn't know at the
time
um
uh what was your next question sorry
what type of asbestos is it blue gray or
white it is now just hold with me i've
got a flick between a few screens here
um it is
uh
cresso tile emma site and crossing
delight forms were detected in two of
the four samples
um and this was fragments of flat cement
sheet and curved cement bound fibrous
materials suspected to be acm
okay so that's white and gray which uh
the white is probably not quite so bad
but do you know where it's um
where it originated from was but was it
pole light or was it some plaster
i have absolutely no idea i'm sorry um
we would have to
um
we only did a preliminary assessment at
this stage um tonka and taylor when they
do further work we'll be able to
determine where it might have come from
but
um i'm not 100 sure and um it's it's
quite a windy spot that um that this has
been dumped um they have the surrounding
houses being sampled for asbestos
uh no no i don't believe they have been
sampled for asbestos we've only done the
actual
site itself um for asbestos and all
we've been able to find is the actual um
compressed bound asbestos on site the
tin samples that we did of the soil
didn't show up any particle asbestos in
them which is a good thing
that means that there's a lot less risk
of any asbestos having moved from the
site
i can't say 100 whether that's the case
but that's what the information is that
we've got from tonkin taylor at the
moment
we are happy to go and seek
further
advice specifically on whether or not
it's something that the council should
look into from tonkin and taylor we hope
you provide that information to the
board
okay
so a big question that all of mandeville
are very um interested in is when's it
going to be gone
uh look i can't give you a date of when
it's going to be gone all i can say is
that we're currently working towards
getting um
mandeville sports club and the council
getting tonkin and taylor to do the
contamination
um
uh disposal disposal management plan um
so until we get that we don't actually
know um what's the best method of
removing it um where we where it would
go to and what that process involves so
we have to go through that process
before we can actually have a date what
we know at the moment is that
in the current form that it's in um it's
safe and will be safe for some time with
that polymer and that fencing around the
outside so that was our main
um our main focus
okay just one last question um
can we make sure that the
mandible sports club board put signs up
at the um all entrances as you're going
in there because at the moment there are
none
and also
if the bowling club is like the other
members most bowlers don't have access
or don't use social media and so is
there some way of getting the board to
communicate with those sports clubs that
use the mandeville sports centre and
they know what they're getting into
sure we'll have a conversation with
mandeville around their communications
that's absolutely not a problem um we
also
um
we're happy to have a conversation again
with the asbestos um
specialist to work out what the risk is
i mean coming in from the main entrance
onto the mandible domain if you're only
going to use the cricut grounds at the
main entrance then there's no risk um
at all with the distance that this
material is away and the fact that we
haven't been able to find anything
within the soil so
we've got signs which are on the outside
of the fence at the moment
on the actual stockpile itself but i'm
happy to get some further advice from
the specialist specifically around the
extent to which we should put signage up
the last thing we want to do is put
signs
far and wide which don't need to be
there
because there's actually no risk
because there are still people that walk
over in that vicinity and and not
necessarily on the cricket grounds they
walk all over the mandeville sports
centre and don't know it's there until
they get right up to the defense
yeah and we'll get advice from the
specialist to let us know whether or not
standing on the other side of the deer
fence is absolutely safe
which i suspect they'll probably say it
is based on the fact that polymer's
there the shade offense is there as well
but i'll certainly ask them that that
exact question to see whether or not we
need to extend the limits of those signs
okay
thank you
thanks for your questions
yeah sarah
yes sarah
yep thank you so much um just a couple
of questions uh number one i just missed
what was your answer about if the
company that dumped the soil as liable
for the mitigations and the removal
costs
so i didn't get asked that question and
i didn't provide an answer to that
question um so thank you for that
question
um
look um i don't know
the answer unfortunately it's something
which mandeville sports club is going to
have to work through um and will assist
them in that process um but but i i
don't know whether or not they're liable
that's that's still um something which
needs to be determined
okay because clearly they would know
what company that was that dumbed it
uh medieval sports club well yes right
okay um and also
maybe
more a comment or no a question in the
future would it be advised for the
mandeville sports club to receive um
soil not necessarily portfolio you can
get the address that soil was coming
from and run it through the christchurch
city council if it's coming from
christchurch and they will soon tell you
if it's coming from a contaminated site
or not so should that not be something
that is necessary for them to do in the
future for any dumping of clean field
just to ensure that this sort of thing
doesn't happen again
yeah yeah absolutely we're working with
medieval sports club at the moment
on
what are the appropriate
processes that you need to go through if
you're going to get fill
of any size from anywhere
and what the rules and regulations are
around that to make sure that
what we've got now is something that
just doesn't happen in the future
correct because it's going to be um i
would
suspect a substantial amount of money
number one just to truck that amount of
soil from site um if it is needing to go
to cape valley and if it has asbestos
having to be wrapped on trucks as it
goes that's the cost of that is going to
be
extremely significant and it's probably
not something that the rate payers
should be really having to pay for
we haven't uh
is that is that would you like me to
respond is that a question
would you agree
well done well done um
look um i i i can't agree or disagree on
the basis that i haven't got a
contamination disposal management plan
from tonkin and taylor so i don't know
what the extent of the asbestos is
within the stockpile at the moment so i
don't know what method they're going to
have to use to actually dispose of that
um yeah worst case scenario
there will be
a cost but at the moment who foots the
bill for that there's something that we
still need to work through
right okay that would be quite uh
something that should i would imagine be
kept um will that be kept public um that
information
um as much information as we can give
the public we will absolutely give the
public um bearing in mind um we wouldn't
want to to jeopardize any possibility to
um
be able to
offset any costs that may come to the
ratepayer through any other process so
anything which we can provide to on the
community board and to the wider public
and those neighbours who are around
mandeville will absolutely make sure
that we're with our communications team
and also
really closely with mandeville to make
sure that with that we get the relevant
information out when we can it's really
important to mandeville sports club
um and to us as a council as well
right and i suppose that follows on to
my uh last question communication is
going to be really important in this
process and keeping everyone um in our
community involved in that
so what is the plan on communication
going forward where is information going
to be
accessible from and rather than people
having to contact you to get that
information is there some form of um
portal or
somewhere to put that so that people can
access it
freely um so generally our council
website and council facebook page my
facebook page usually links back to our
website so
when we release information you'll be
able to find it on our council website
um with the mandeville sports club um
we'll also be having a look at how
they're going to disseminate that
information as well um we'll be meeting
with the medical sports club um very
soon to have a look at um where that
comms come from comes from and what the
comms is actually saying um we need to
be be careful with what that comms um is
um and and release the information um
that's relevant and that we can um so i
can't give you an exact place at the
moment however if the council will
release anything um you'll be able to
find it on the um on the council website
right okay so keeping i think keeping
the process open and transparent as
possible is gonna be very important and
the property that is directly next door
to this i mean some of that soil
is basically on their boundary and they
would probably be
eager to know that they
have not got any um asbestos because
let's face that one when when that board
is crumbled and moved and that's when
the dust comes and and it could
potentially be in some areas of um of
that fill um
they
yeah they just seemed very very close to
the location of where that is have they
been contacted at all about this
directly
i'm pretty sure that the neighbors um
whether they've been contacted directly
most of them have made contact with me
specifically
or some of my other staff
and so as i mentioned earlier someone
asked the question as to whether or not
we would test nearby properties
i will specifically go back and ask
tonkin and taylor whether they would
recommend that there's something that we
should do based on the information that
they have at the moment from the um
preliminary testing that they've done
and i'll let the board know what the
outcome of um
of that advice is
okay great thank you for that chris
thank you cheers for your questions
uh any further questions
um chris thank you for all of those
questions and
well done with all the rest of you with
asking some pretty comprehensive
questions in this situation
just in the interest of preventing this
from happening again as part of the
process
with msc can we ensure that advice is
given to them when and why resource
consents are required
because i think um if a few more
questions had been asked along the way
we wouldn't be sitting here
it appears that those involved seem to
have done the wrong thing for the right
reasons and um
yeah just really in the interest of
ensuring it doesn't happen again can we
put something into training for for
people involved
yeah so absolutely um we're already
talking to mandeville sports club um on
a regular basis and um we'll be letting
them know processes and procedures that
they need to to go through when um uh
moving phil um
uh in in in similar type things and the
rules and regulations around them
um you're absolutely right um
they um you know they're really good
reasons um the community reasons um why
the soil was moved here you know to
create a walking and cycling track so
um it's an unfortunate situation which
we find ourselves in
um but yeah we'll make sure that it
doesn't happen again
okay
uh anyone else
yeah i've got a couple more thank you
uh just
and moving forward uh considering the
board and um
where where they are situated at the
moment are they getting um help from us
from the start because they will be
going through
quite a
terrible time at the moment
regarding the soil contamination and
the worry and such like so are they
getting they're getting help from the
staff
uh they are um getting help from from
staff um uh waimakariri um staff as well
as um also um
uh board members themselves actually um
doing quite a lot of work in this space
as well
they've been very committed
and concerned
um and and yes it is very difficult for
for those members of the the mandeville
board but they're taking it very
seriously and i think they're doing
absolutely all of the right things at
the moment um to make sure they can get
this resolved um four mandible sports
club
um they are a very dedicated group of
volunteers who look after mandeville
sports club
you know they put their heart and soul
into it and and they do it for the
community um um so so you know this is
difficult for for them as well but we'll
give them absolutely all the help that
we can possibly um give them and and i'm
absolutely i'm sure that um they'll be
doing what are doing everything that
they can possibly do as well so
yeah
okay
all right anybody else hold your hand up
for a while rather than flashing it
thomas
thank you um
this is a multi-part question um there's
been lots of talk about
asbestos tonight
have in terms of their initial testing
have tonk and taylor done any testing
into other substances that are in it
like coulter or heavy metals or
chemicals or anything like that and
because of that is there any risk to the
groundwater below because we know
mandeville's
quite stony and quite poor as ground
um and if there is
a situation where there could be
leaching into the groundwater it could
happen quite fast so is there something
have they done that in their initial
testing and are they going to do it or
are they going to do it going forward
they have thomas
i'm just flicking between a few
pages here they've done tests for heavy
metals
polyurethane polyaromatic
hydrocarbons and total petroleum
hydrocarbons
um and those they found those to be
below background levels
so that's really positive it's a good
question um that you raised but um no
they haven't found those to be
um at levels that would be um of a
concern for human health so that's
really good
and so going forward when they do this
more comprehensive testing which which
sounds like they're doing soon um are
they going to be just surface samples or
are they going to be actually excavating
the piles and getting to the bottom of
them and actually doing a full like
cross section of a of a pile
here there and everywhere sort of thing
or how will that work i'm i'm i'm as
much of an expert as as everyone else
probably is here
i rely on tonkin and taylor one one
would assume though um to make sure that
it was
a
proper analysis that they would
obviously go
further than the surface samples that
they've done at the moment but i don't
know what the method methodology is
thomas i'm happy to
um once that's
once they've done it um clearly we'll be
happy to share that with the board
no we've got ray
doug
right
thank you just one last question while
i've got you there chris um
to do with the mandeville sports centre
but nothing to do with asbestos um
i have asked the board this on a couple
of occasions regarding uh walkways and
cycle ways that developers have
that have surrounded the mandeville
sports centre have left that that lead
into the mandeville sports centre uh
wonderful idea but at this stage they're
all fenced off
and uh my my question is is there any
um any prospect of
those being able to be used to access
the mandeville sports centre by the
local residents
um
yeah i mean that's the purpose of why
they are there right um but i don't know
the um operational details of um why
these fences i do know previously we had
active forest around the outside of
mandeville today but most of that's been
removed now and they're looking at the
creation of that walk-in cycling track
so i think i think the plan is to open
those um in the future um but it's a
great question and tia i'm sure we'll be
writing that down
um and you know it'll uh we'll we'll get
back to you and let you know exactly
what the um
exactly what the the answer is i don't
know sorry but it
there will be a reason why um but over i
think the intention is eventually
they'll be opened up
thank you
sarah
all right just last question um
just to wonder will you be seeking legal
advice as to who is capable for the
expense of the removal of this when it
comes to it
um
mandeville sports club um and the
council um will both be um
uh working
with our
respective
uh lawyers to
ask some questions and um
you know we will leave it up to the
lawyers to to work through that
um i i um
i don't know what the result of that
will be clearly um but yes
anymore
right that's it all right thank you very
much chris thanks doug appreciate it
thank you
thanks chris
okay thank you
moving on
now during business
reports
okay
through you mr jefferson
oh
oh can we start
go ahead yeah okay through you mr
jefferson the first report is the
application for grant funding
from the
oxford art trust they want to purchase
the air purifier that they want to use
in the large facility so that they can
continue the classes for which they
received
government funding last year
i'll take the reporters read and answer
any questions that members may have
questions sarah
is that a necessary thing to have to be
able to conduct there
continue with your lessons
i don't believe it's necessary i believe
that they want to
comply as far as possible with the
guidelines that set
by the government and they feel that
this is the easiest way to
ensure their members
that will be actually attending the
classes that they will be safe
you understand what i'm saying
anyone else
yes
thank you um
should um
should we um
give them this this funding for it um
i'm just a little bit concerned about
the number of people that they will be
having in there
for their um
for their program i just hope it's not
too many for that research has a big
room
but i'm just i'm hoping that they're not
going to have too many people
participating at one time
because i don't know whether the ear
purifier
would cope with too large of a group of
people
through you mr chippers even though they
will have the p um air purifier they
will still have to comply with the
government regulations in terms of
gatherings
so um
they they they
i what the way i understood is that the
air purifier was an additional
safeguard that they want to implement to
ensure the safety of the people who are
attending the classes
all right
sarah
um is
is there any reason in their room that
they're in or anything that they can't
space themselves we have masks do what
other
people were doing
or is there a specific reason that the
room they're in is not suitable for
ventilating other ways or wearing uh
social distancing and that sort of thing
through you mr chairperson i'm sorry i
won't be able to answer that i'm not
afraid with the room that they will be
holding the classes in
wendy is yes mainly yeah it is a large
room
but it it doesn't have um through
ventilation like this doesn't it it
doesn't have windows everywhere it's
just got two doors
so i can i can understand why they're um
wanting to have something else there
because you can't just throw open a
window
um and let me ventilate right through it
it is a big building a big
area and it has got a high roof
but it's still not uh it doesn't have a
lot of
windows just a couple of doors
anybody else
i would suggest that we consider
um giving them 699 dollars to cover the
full cost of this purifier
but that's only my suggestion
are you moving that mr2 person
uh no i won't move it we'll wait for a
motion
from
the floor first
but that's my suggestion
wendy
yeah i'll move
um that we
give them that they have requested 500
dollars
um
but i um
what i'd like to just make sure that i
go and visit them to see make sure that
this is
the right
all our questions are answered
before we hand over the money
it has the 5 i will say the 500 but with
um a a um clausen at that
that um
the questions that we ask will make will
meet the standard for you having that
facility
yes and and if you could find out if the
volume of air in that room is suitable
for that particular um thing because if
you say it does have high ceilings and
it's a large space
is it
even
going to do anything
yeah
yeah okay yep
right we've got a motion another second
right
any further discussion
all right all in favor
put your hand up if you're in favor
please
events
it's carried thank you
mr chair
yes
um i will go and speak with them
tomorrow
if they're open
and i will email there with with the
information required
okay thank you very much
right move on to
the community plan
here
thank you mr chairperson
this is the
community the updated community plan and
all the information for 2021 has been
um included and updated by the various
departments
um we're just asking
the board to approve the updated plan
after the board approval it will then go
to creative admin to make it pretty in
terms of layout and photos and
everything like that
and then after they
settled on the creative side we will
submit it to the chairperson for final
signing off
the board gets the report like this
every year
so it's basically straightforward and
this plan is
mostly used as promotional material for
board activities
and made it available at all the council
service centers
i'm happy to ask any answer any
questions
any questions
just sorry um well i suppose actually
you did just actually answer that i was
just going to ask
there's a few typos in it
its contents generally pretty good but
yeah so someone's going to go over that
with a fine toothed film then
yes no it will be good and it will be
also
the layout and every thing will be fixed
great
thanks
all right thank you
okay we'll leave that in your favorable
hands to you
um we just need somebody to move and
second
i'll move thank you
see you guys
hi minnie
oh nikki yep okay all in favor
against
gary thank you
correspondence there isn't any
chairperson before
yeah person through you um
shirley forwarded a letter from
um about the
main street street main speed limits
to all the members that she asked she
would just like the board's input
on the letter
to community board members today
surely you want to make some comments
unfortunately shirley can't make
comments mr bear because her speaker is
not working but thomas has a question
yeah thank you um
uh could we will this be forwarded to
the council's roading staff and can we
get a bit of a please explain from them
because it's a bit contradictory to what
they've been telling us for the last
six months or so um
not even longer than that like four
years
so um yeah it'd be good to get a bit of
a please explain from them and then
could we also afford it at the council
as well because i'm not sure if we had a
reply to our leader that we sent them
three or four months ago but um this
would be probably good to go along with
that as well thank you
you're mr chairperson i've already
forwarded the letter to the um council's
trans eroding transport and roading
department and i have spoken to joanne
personally and she is dealing with the
matter in terms of the letter that we or
the board sent to the council
the mayor's office is in the process of
setting up a meeting
with the um
board members and joanne
to discuss various issues that the board
raised about the speed limits where
after we can report back to
the board as a whole
okay and when do we think that's going
to be happening any ideas
unfortunately i don't know but i'm sure
it's going to be as soon as possible i
just know that
everybody seems to be quite busy to get
all parties
um together but we hopeful it will be
done before the next board meeting
thank you
anyone else
yes
i'd just like to say surely that was
that
letter did make very interesting reading
and i only wish that we had it sooner
um
it was quite uh
a revelation to see what waka kotahi had
to say
versus you know what we thought
was the case so um yeah i i it does make
me wonder
if
if it had come sooner if it might have
been a bit more
um helpful to our cause but yeah well
done in getting that thanks
thank you
else
yes sir
so just so that i understand uh we were
at with this so this has already gone
through its um process with council and
they've already declined that would that
speed limit would occur
due to this
information coming through is there any
way that that could potentially
cause a re-look at it because it's
and a new
new and new inclusion or something
perhaps
through you mr chairperson i think tracy
might be in a better position or the
mayor even will be in the best position
to answer that
um
yes please
if it's permitted mr chair i only
received the letter today so i haven't
had a chance to
um
consider it fully but i will on the
train i hold the transport portfolio
council
so i'll get my full attention
and we'll come back to you around there
including
options around process but
as was mentioned before very happy
we will have a meeting within the next
month before the board meeting the next
board meeting and i'll be in a position
to advise you uh then with our um with
joanna transport manager so
um just give us a little bit of time to
consider that it's very helpful to have
had that shirley so thank you um and uh
we will come back to you and advise you
through tier
two
tracy do you want to say something
no
um no i think um mayor dan's explain
where the process is at and in terms of
um the ability in terms of process to
review that decision
there you know there are options always
of course but it'll be a question around
timing and because that decision has
been made understand by council so there
are um i guess processes and procedures
around if that was going to get
revisited um but that i'm sure form part
of the thinking and discussion
once that information has been
considered
right sorry if i just further um to that
might be helpful once we've given that
feedback that the board consider that as
part of its annual plan submission
uh to add that point in there that would
be an opportunity for the council to
revisit it on that point as well but
we'll come back to you with further
advice but that's my initial reaction
thank you
anyone else
no any good
right
chairperson's report
i attended the
ohio rural drainage advisory board
group
meeting in
february
and there was considerable opposition to
the
idea of the uh
subdivision going in that lake
and i also attended the north carolina
neighborhood support meeting last week
um
[Music]
and the
manager who's been employed 20 hours a
week they've
been looking at upping her areas to 30
years a week she's doing a very good job
that's it for me for me somebody moved
that we accept that report
ray and secondary thomas
all in favor
gary thank you
better for information
item 11.132
point
one one so we move that we
accept those reports
thomas thank you second up
sarah are you all in favor
against
public excluded
there
thank you mr chairperson um this is just
for noting so you can just note
it similar to the
items
that you've just noted
right
so you can actually just include it in
your um
the the previous motion if i can say it
to lunchtime
thank you
um mr jefferson it seems that sarah has
a question
so yeah yes
no
why are you waving your hands here
okay no question from sarah so we'll
move on
members information exchange
um okay
we'll start with thomas and
go backwards from there
right thank you i haven't done a lot
this month um we had an actual advisory
group meeting um it was quite productive
um
and we farewelled the chairperson jan
who's retiring from the group and we
also farewelled the camp managers who
are leaving
they left
on monday monday was their last day so
uh the group got them a gift to thank
them for eight or nine years i think
they've been there and they've done a
tremendous job um
to be honest i've left big shoes to fill
for the net cam managers they've done a
great job maintaining the reserve and
keeping it presentable for the community
and it's made the job of the
actual advisory group very easy to work
with them and
get stuff done around the around the
place
um but other than that i've spent
probably the last two weeks just
fielding complaints about the situation
of mandeville with the soil that we
discussed earlier
um i think i've had about 20 phone calls
today about it so um
yeah it's good to get some answers and
we'll be able to go back to the public
now when they phone up and actually tell
them what's happening
which is a lot better than the situation
i was in before this so thank you
are you doing this right
right your turn
there we are
um not a lot going on um
in february i attended the
uh a hoka drainage um uh meeting uh
things seem to be trucking along there
and uh as doug mentioned uh it was a big
surprise to most members there that um
there was a um
an application in for uh 800 sections in
ohio
and um i think there was there was quite
a bit of shock amongst the
members that that they um
there's the possibility of such a
development
great power yesterday um i didn't go for
covered reasons and um
i've got nothing else to report
yeah you're right sarah
um yeah same uh february hasn't been the
month of my uh general meetings but um
so i've just got the the same with
everyone else a wee bit disappointed
with the
time it took to get information about
the soil at um at mandeville it was not
a good feeling when people were asking
you questions about it and other people
know more than you do um at the time
um also
fielding fair bit of uh questions and
talk about the ahoka development um a
lot of negative negativity around that
um at the moment but be interesting to
get more information about that as it as
it comes through
um and also
as mentioned before just the concern of
the current water table levels um
around at the moment uh um notably as
high as they have been in
peak winter times
so it will be very interesting to know
if there's any um thought about whether
this needs to be something um
that needs to be addressed in and
coming up through the winter time like
where we're starting at a baseline level
that's extremely high um where is that
going to leave us
so um
that's about that for me thank you
thank you sarah
shirley we know you've been busy um but
you can't tell us about it sorry about
that
counsellors
which one first
um sorry mr jefferson through you
shirley has sent us a note
on what she's been doing now please just
read it into the record yes please
and now silly has sent me more notes
no oxford a historical society meeting
no pearson park advisory group meeting
she's still concerned about the damage
to the toilets and community garden in
pearson park which has once again been
damaged
also just to let members know that the
oxford farmers market would like to see
the ev car park available 24 7 and i
wish that we should advise vanessa of
there
they haven't used the car park for over
eight years and now it
is sealed they could um put up tin they
could not put the 10 pinks in the seal
and that is what the note that she has
sent us
thank you shirley
oh councillors
who's first
don't rush us okay thank you wendy thank
you um i recently
attended an oxford rural drainage
advisory board
meeting um though very very concerned
about the
amount of water that's
been flowing down mountain stream
unfortunately uh just above there
there's been a huge amount of um
work
done uh removing trees and so there's a
lot of very loose
soil that just running off and into the
stream and
starting to block block up areas and
actually getting into the waterway so
that they're very concerned about that
um
because it's it's causing problems
downstream nazis
areas downstream and causing the last
lot of flooding that was created was
simply because
of the the amount of
soil and
and uh stones and shingles and such like
in that that stream that created by work
that was done up on on the um hill above
so they um
they've just
said to the staff about it that they're
really concerned about and and i would
like to see
perhaps a little bit more work done on
it
because it is also affecting
the uh waterway for
um not rural number two as well because
they've got a
pipeline and then i've had to move that
because of the
damage done
um
the oxford pool um
they're really struggling with lack of
staff and
they may have to close it early i hope
that isn't going to be the case but
they
they're really struggling to to man up
and we just haven't got anybody coming
in
wanting to be
you know to work there um unfortunately
um just for that we always used to have
the students here but not being just few
and far between they didn't want to do
it so
hopefully
we can we can um keep it going through
which would be very good if we can but i
just give you a heads up but
things are a little bit dire there
um the ashy gorge campground i really
would just like to say um
an appreciation of the previous
camper camp
ground operators
you know they've had
uh three really major events that have
happened there while they were in their
tube
first one was when the
house that they were living in called
fire
and they had to live almost
nine months i think something like that
they had to be in a caravan which was
through the middle of winter time
and they were camping in
in facilities and such like then really
it was pretty substandard for people to
have to manage that through the winter
months there
they also then had two lots of flooding
um that which flooded their basement of
their
home wrecked um ruined a lot of this
stock and their
such like so they had thrown away a lot
of that then they had another flooding
that was the same that went down through
the basement and then last of course of
all was when the ashy gorge river
flooded right across the base the bottom
terrace of it and caused major major
damage
and they've had a lot of work and
they've had a lot of issues to put up
with so i really appreciate
what silly and wayne have done
and i wish them all very the best for
their
what they're going to be doing moving
forward i spoke to him on sunday and he
was actually quite happy to be on his
way
so thank you
are you ready
thanks for that wendy um yeah i think
i'll just start off with just the
community stuff in addition to obviously
the soil issue we've been discussing um
there's there's been a lot of interest
and discussion in the community about
the yohoka plan change proposal and that
continued field a lot of queries from
the public and the press
it's been a yeah that's been fun
it's also been a busy month for water
related issues
on the 9th of february before our last
flooding event i
went to visit a property on mill road
of a residence that
had some issues with the drain and then
later on discussed that with
green spaces and drainage
and passed on some photos of that
because it was a bit of
two things um
and then on the 11th i got a call from
mandeville resident that had an issue
due to a contractor who
ray harper put me on to or put on to me
um that
that um
his tank ran dry because a contractor um
inadvertently forgot to turn it back on
so
we got in touch with the with our waters
manager and
um i i do take my hat off to the water
team they they quickly got onto that
they removed the restrictor to refill
the gentleman's tank and rechecked all
the contractors works to make sure that
they hadn't done that to anybody else
and that the problem was more widespread
and they'll reimburse the resident for
his pump servicing bill because he had
to call somebody in to re-prime at three
times so it was a happy resolution there
but nonetheless um
yeah something that was um better to get
on top of uh with the with the rain
event on the 12th and 13th of february
um just like
i guess i tend to do and a lot of you
guys do as well you know did my best to
keep people informed on social media
channels and also drove around to
around the immediate area just to check
to see how our drainage was faring in
the known trouble spots um i
observed the wilson drive flooding which
um has only really just started to get
you know some notice but that
that particular road does
flood quite regularly whenever we have
rainfall events and um
also
noted that
further an email had been sent about
concerns from rain the week prior in the
ohoka domain um the white throat
entrance by the gatehouse
was quite muddy from the week before and
of course you know this is unheard of
it's summer and we have mud in the
domain which
you know has never happened before this
time last year they were complaining
that the lawn mowers were kicking at
dust because it was that dry and now we
have mud you know welcome to climate
change guys
um but
during this flooding event
the
drains on both sides of the roads were
full it was running across from the farm
into the drain on the west side going
across the road
into already full drains on the east
side and then going down into this
driveway and i could just see that it
wasn't going to be a pretty picture for
all of the hookah farmers market vendors
to be driving in through there so
um got on to that with
grant and he organized a meeting with
the
ohoka domain advisory group and
the hookah farmers market organizer and
myself to go and have a look at it on a
thursday which was only one by the time
he could get everybody together it was
just a day before the farmers market so
you know it's not really like they had a
lot of time to
call it off because it's quite a
juggernaut of a thing um you know a
hundred stalls or so and their
associated vehicles and whatnot and all
the thousands of people that come to it
so um i was i was quite proud of our
staff actually and and also the parties
that came to talk about it and that
they all agreed yes it's a problem they
very quickly and i mean quickly acted to
fix it
um within one hour after that meeting
our staff went away got a dump truck of
of um
some was it called ap40 sorry that's a
sierra sarah and thomas question um of
gravel to put over it and averted
mud bath disaster for the next um
for the next day which was great to see
and they'll be looking into i'm sorting
that out
and further to the
wilson drive issue i've passed that on
and shown photos and and whatnot of the
the situation of wilton drive i went to
visit a resident that has
the the drain in question that causes
this problem i'm on their property and
had a good look at that to just
understand it and sat down with um with
our
you and our manager
overall to have a good look at that and
see what we can do about it
on the 15th of february the culvert
bridge over the hoca stream on butcher's
road failed which is fun
thankfully nobody was hurt and you know
they're looking at at um
getting that sorted out as soon as
possible uh it's just
you know the amount of water that has
come through the hoca stream and
downstream of you know all these very
wet areas in in the middle of
winter or sorry you know it is expected
but summer is just unheard of i'm a
theory you're right to actually ask with
our high water table now i mean i have
lived here for 23 years and i have never
seen this in summer it's incredible i
can guarantee you that the undercurrent
will definitely be flowing and um it
will be an interesting year but uh you
know groundwater's groundwater and
there's not a lot we can do about it
um we can only just
try to get the drainage going as well as
we can
um
and on the 22nd of just kind of jumping
around a little bit we
um observed
the anniversary of the canterbury
earthquake at 12 51 which
i'm sure you all agree is
certainly an important
milestone to mark and
a sad one for various reasons for us all
going back to meetings
um
we
i suppose probably a few of you said in
on that had an all board zoom about our
um about
wdc's three waters position and our
community's involvement and
sorry and our involvement in communities
for local democracy so basically as you
guys would be aware 60 out of 6
attempted councils oppose the
government's current proposal and i
think we're sitting at about 29 councils
so far that have joined
communities for local democracy i don't
know if that's the 29 dan
and um
on the 10th of feb there was the hookah
rural drainage advisory group meeting
which of course had
ray and doug
as well um
interesting that there was a i noted
that there was a very strong opinion
that the undercurrent should be
channeled to the waimakariri river
rather than the old air riverbed amongst
the members um
but that's a very long trench to dig so
it'll be interesting to see where they
get with that
um
ashworth's road
and the maintenance update was seen as
the the worst in in the ahoka drainage
area um in the december event
and they also discussed rake attachment
versus bucket versus glyphosate methods
as a proposed trial because raking seems
to be increasing weed growth which is
not ideal
audit and risk committee
on the 15th the capital works program is
quite behind schedule largely due to
supply chain issues and resourcing in a
tight labor market and i'm sure that
that will be no surprise to any of you
guys but yeah it's tough out there
on the 16th of feb was the prevention of
alcohol and drug harm steering group
which i and one of the other members
turned up and found that sadly our
lovely natalie who has chaired this
group has accepted a role closer to home
in um the hernia district council but
luckily we have martin who from our
community team who will take over in the
interim but
that's something that i'm keen to see
going forward
with dpnr district planning and
regulation the
update that the planning unit gave us
there's a 59 increase between
2020 and 2021
we managed to
process 96.5 percent
of the
applications within the statutory time
frames which is not as good as usual but
better than our other canterbury
councils anecdotally
um and the rc compliance and monitoring
is trending upward sounds exciting right
i know um
we also had a briefing on tiny homes as
we'd requested because everybody kind of
wonders is it a building is it a vehicle
um there's a really nice little guide
that they gave to us that answered a few
questions
uh our
on the 22nd as well we had the
waimakariri
in addition to
yeah several meetings on the 22nd um the
waimakariri youth council had a zoom
with their
including their seven new members
which is exciting i'm looking forward to
getting to know those guys and seeing
what they can achieve for our district
youth and um
on the 28th there was a north canterbury
youth services networking
meeting which is a first of its kind
which had attendees from our council
christchurch hiranui
also youth town canterbury youth
collective
i think that's most of them and emily
our youth development manager is looking
to complete a youth development
directory in a map to help connect young
people to services and interests so
that's something that we don't have
right now all in one place where people
can go to so
that'll be quite good too
to get underway but
yes and of course yesterday was a
council meeting but um
not really a whole lot in there um
specific to
our
award so are there any questions guys
then that's it for me
thanks
thank you for that
and
you heard something else say me no
right
we have to receive those reports here
no mr chairperson we can just move on to
consultation projects oh yeah right
consultation projects
these scooters
and draft annual plan
that's just for noting sir
nothing to report on that
yep
and board funding update
discretionary grant stands at 4887
and the landscaping budget at 12 710.
sorry through you mr chippers and now i
just remind the members to please
um promote the board discretionary grant
in the communities we have that funding
available and we're already in march
we've only got three months
left of this financial year and i'm sure
that there's organizations out there
that actually need our support
thank you
thank you
no media items no questions
understanding orders
no urgent business understanding orders
the next meeting
will be held at the mandeville sports
centre if we have a physical meeting
on monday
the 6th of april 2022 at 7 pm
i will close the meeting
excuse me did you say monday
i said monday because that's what it got
written here
can i just confirm that because i i
i doubt that it is a monday mr jefferson
i'll come back to members on that
the sixth is a wednesday
thank you
wonder gonna read it out but it's
already
right
anything we need to workshop thomas you
heard something at the beginning we
want to discuss that more
sorry yeah i'll just be good
sorry can i just hang on a moment that i
just um
switch off the audio streaming please
you